in 2021 the physicist Stephen coonan who
served as under secretary for science in
the Obama Administration energy
Department published the best-selling
unsettled what climate science tells us
what it doesn't and why it matters the
book attracted extremely negative
reviews filled with ad hominem attacks
such as a short statement appearing in
Scientific American signed by 12
academics that instead of dealing with
the substance of the book calls the
author a crank who's only taken
seriously by far-right disinformation
Peddlers hungry for anything they can
use to score political points and just
another denier trying to sell a book I
couldn't find a single negative review
of unsettled that disputed its claims
directly or even described them
accurately many of the reviewers seem to
have stopped reading after the first few
pages others were forced to concede that
many of coonan's facts were correct but
objected that they were used in the
service of challenging official Dogma
true statements were downplayed as
trivia video or his things everyone
knows despite the extensive parts of
unsettled that documented precisely the
opposite when dissenting scientists are
implicitly compared to Holocaust deniers
are there ideas considered to be too
dangerous to be carefully considered and
undermines public respect for the field
and can lead to catastrophic policy
mistakes it's human nature to favor
evidence that confirms our biases and
leads to simple conclusions but for
science to advance it's essential that
moral certainty not override objective
discussion and that personal attacks not
replace rational consideration of
empirical evidence
in a review of unsettled in Scientific
American Gary Yohi an Emeritus professor
at Wesleyan University gives the
impression that he didn't read past the
first few pages the book has nine
chapters filled with examples of
exaggerations and outright falsehoods in
both scientific and popular accounts
Yohi mentions just four claims taken
from the first two pages plus one from a
chapter subtitle and manages to refute
none of them he seizes on the assertion
which appears on page two that the
warmest temperatures in the U.S have not
risen in the past 50 years according to
what measures Yohe writes highest Global
averages absolutely not if he had
bothered to keep reading yo he would
have found a detailed account of
precisely what measure Conan was using
and the evidence at record high
temperatures in the U.S are no more
common than they were in the 1970s Yohe
attacks coonan's assertion that heat
waves in the U.S are now no more common
than they were in 1900 claiming that
this is a questionable statement
depending on the definite edition of
heat wave and so it is really
uninformative heat waves are poor
indicators of heat stress if Yohi had
read carefully he would have found the
official Heat Wave index used and why it
matters he offers no evidence that heat
stress something even less well-defined
and hence less informative than Heat
Wave is greater than in 1900. Yohe also
focuses on the first word of the book's
title unsettled he claims that coonan
deploys that highly misleading label to
falsely suggest that we don't understand
the risks well enough to take action
actually coonan's argument is that
claims of harm from Human climate
impacts have been exaggerated and are
misrepresented in the press and that we
should undertake more sensible and
longer-term policies than many activists
and politicians currently advocate in
another article published on the website
of the Union of concerned scientists
Yohi writes that although coonan is a
very skilled and well-respected
physicist he should follow the approach
of those on the front lines people who
know what they are doing because they
have doing this for 15 years Conan has
been attacked by others for not being a
climate Scientist by trade in most
dogmatic religions only the anointed are
granted the authority to speak but
science is supposed to be a discipline
that's open to anyone who can interpret
the relevant material unsettled is a
book you can accurately judge by its
cover wrote Mark boslow a fellow of the
committee for skeptical inquiry in Yale
climate review connections and it seems
as if he barely read further
he denies that anyone in the media
politics or otherwise of prominence has
claimed that climate science has settled
he ignores all of the book's substantive
points because the cover was the only
part worth reading coonan is accused of
having cherry-picked and carelessly
misrepresented many of his sources by
Bob Ward the policy and communications
director at the London School of
Economics Grantham Research Institute on
climate change though his refutations
are weak at least Ward does seem to have
read the book in one chapter coonan
takes the media to task for its
overheated account of the link between
human CO2 emissions and hurricane
frequency such as a USA Today article
headlined global warming is making
hurricanes stronger study says the
article States unequivocally that human
cause global warming has strengthened
the wind speeds of hurricanes typhoons
and Cyclones around the globe coonan
points out that the study on which that
article is based doesn't make that claim
with such certainty goodin quotes
directly from the study but Ward accuses
him of having omitted an another excerpt
from the same paper which reads from a
storyline balance of evidence or type 2
error avoidance perspective the
consistency of the trends identified
here with expectations based on physical
understanding and greenhouse warming
simulations increases confidence that
TCS have become substantially stronger
and that there is a likely human
fingerprint on this increase word must
be confused about what that sentence
means because it doesn't support the USA
Today article or under mine coonan's
point
that passage is saying that although
there is only suggestive evidence that
tropical Cyclones have gotten stronger
we're better off assuming that they are
and that humans are partly responsible
coonan likely agrees with that statement
and he certainly correct that it doesn't
justify unambiguous headlines like
global warming is making hurricanes
stronger study says
after coonan wrote a Wall Street Journal
op-ed entitled Greenland's melting ice
is no cause for climate change panic in
February 2022 an organization called
climate feedback which calls itself a
worldwide network of scientists sorting
fact from fiction and climate change
media coverage published a response it
labeled coonan's article cherry-picking
flawed reasoning lack of context
misleading the point of coonan's op-ed
was straightforward and illustrated by
this graph while Greenland is losing ice
the main driver cannot be anthropogenic
climate change because there is no
steady increase in line with either
human CO2 emissions her atmospheric
concentrations of CO2 carbon dioxide
emissions and warming may be important
but other factors were clearly more
important in the past coonan also
acknowledged that the United Nations
intergovernmental panel on climate
change projects that for the most likely
course of greenhouse gas emissions in
the 21st century the average annual ice
loss would be somewhat larger than the
peak value shown in the graph how is it
cherry picking to show all the data
Columbia University's Marco Tedesco
claims that the article picks only the
last 10 years excluding the remaining
time series for the context and yet the
graph published in the op-ed clearly
shows the data since 1900 and addresses
all of it ironically the climate
feedback review is guilty of cherry
picking it claims to rebut coonan by
stating that a 2015 article in nature
found that the ice loss between 2003 and
2010 not only more than doubled relative
to the
1983-2003 period but also relative to
the net Mass loss rate throughout the
20th century in other words climate
feedback picked the fastest eight-year
increase over the 121-year span shown on
the chart and compared it to the lowest
21 years that's the definition of cherry
picking it's also Irrelevant for the
climate change debate because both
periods occurred in the time period of
Rapid global warming generally taken to
have begun in 1970 or shortly before
Eric rignard of the University of
California Irvine who contributed to
climate feedback's attempt to rebeccunan
dismisses the op-ed by claiming that
it's rehashing the old argument that the
1930s were warmer than the present which
is false when in fact that's not the
argument and has nothing to do with
coonan's point in another climate
feedback article this went a review of a
video that had made to summarize
his book Southern Illinois University's
Justin schoof disputes coonan's claim
that the U.S heat waves are no more
common today than in 1900. the 2018 U.S
climate assessment shows that heat wave
season the United States has increased
in length since the 1960s he writes this
is doubly irrelevant since it refers to
a different metric and a different time
period than coonan referred to to make
matters worse shuf is citing precisely
the data that coonan explains are
misleading in his book
why does it matter that coonan's critics
don't want to bother responding to his
arguments substantive debate is how
science advances if climate science is
just an echo chamber we may make
perverse short-term over-reactions to
the data that have large costs and
possibly even negative environmental
consequences many historical policy
disasters have been caused by people
claiming they shouldn't have to engage
with informed critics unsettled is about
more than just climate policy it seeks
to free science from the shackles of
organized Dogma the sole domain of an
anointed Elite who feel justified in
calling their critics cranks deniers and
disinformation Peddlers why engage with
a heretic when he can be banished from
the church altogether
[Music]